Welcome to this
episode of UXD where
I'll share best practices
for designing and building
location-based mobile apps
that are sure to delight
smartphone users
who are on-the-go.
This is the first episode
of a three-part series where
we will focus on the
design implications driven
by the ergonomics of
single-handed navigation
and location-based
apps that use maps.
I'm your host, Nazmul
Idris, a developer
advocate passionate
about design and mobile.
Now before we dive
into the specifics
of building well-designed
location-based apps,
we need to know more about
how actual users interact
with location-based technology.
And to understand this, we
have to look at their context.
So what is context?
Well, the user's context is
driven by the amount of time
a user has to accomplish a goal,
the tasks that they're going
to perform to accomplish this
goal using a variety of devices
and applications, where
they're physically located,--
for example, at home, at
work, or at an airport--
and what their state of mind is.
Are they happy?
Are they stressed out?
Do they want to be alone?
Or do they want to
be with friends?
Now, all these things drive how
people choose devices they use,
and it also affects their
expectations from apps
that they're running
on these devices.
Now, typically research
and planning tasks
are done on tablets and
laptops, but execution tasks
are done on
smartphones, where users
have bursty and intense
interactions with their device.
Now, while they're busy doing
other things, and as a result
they could be really distracted.
So when you put
this all together,
there's a good chance that
location-based apps running
on smartphones will be used
by people to perform execution
tasks while they're on the go.
In other words,
to understand this
just picture yourself
standing at a busy airport.
You have a bag in one hand.
You're on your way to the gate.
And you're trying to
use your smartphone
to find a place to get coffee.
So let's pick apart
this use case.
Now, before we get into
the specifics of designing
and building an application
that helps you get your coffee,
there is one problem
at hand which
is, how do you allow the
user to find a coffee
shop on the map
using a single hand?
So, when you consider
the human hand
and how people hold
their phones and which
parts of the touchscreen
are easy to touch,
we bump into some real
physical constraints.
Human hands can only
move in certain ways,
regardless of how a designer
envisioned the perfect visual
and interaction design.
This is why UX is industrial
design and not fine art.
The goal of industrial design
is to create and execute
design solutions for problems of
form, usability and ergonomics,
while taking the user and all
these constraints into account.
And these constraints
apply to any type
of location-based
application that you
might be building and designing.
So now it's really important
to respect these constraints,
or in other words, respect
the hardware form factor.
And by hardware, I
mean the user's hand.
This picture shows
you that interactions
that require a user
to move their thumb
to the red or orange
touch areas on the screen
are going to be
difficult to accomplish.
And the red areas are much
worse for single-handed touch
than the orange areas.
So the green areas on the screen
are the most comfortable areas
for someone to
touch with one hand.
So this means that
you should try
to design the UI in such a
way that the widgets that
require the most
touch interaction
should be placed
in the green area
and less ideally in
the orange, and try
to avoid the red
areas altogether.
This will result
in an app that's
easy to use with just
a single hand or thumb.
Now, keep in mind
that this picture
is for right handed
users who make up
over 70% of people in the world.
Here's another fun fact.
About 50% of users tend
to hold their phones
in one hand which
means that they're
using the phone
with a single thumb.
This is what the
thumb zone looks
like when you overlap both the
left and right-handed users
onto the same surface.
If you wanted to
create an app that's
usable by both left
and right-handed users,
then this is a good
reference to keep in mind.
So looking at this picture,
avoid the stretch zones
if possible, and definitely
avoid the ow zones.
And try to keep the touch
interaction centered
in the thumb zone.
For more details
on the ow zone, you
should read this great
article by Scott Hurff.
And there's also
a great book that
covers this in detail called
"Designing Mobile Interfaces."
So, what should we do with
this new found knowledge
of the human hand
and how people use
their smartphones
with a single hand?
How do we make a more usable
coffee locator application?
We could leverage
these constraints
to create better designs
for any location-based apps,
not just coffee
finding apps that
are going to be used
by humans with hands.
Let's dive into some specifics.
So here's the first
best practice.
Try to avoid the use
of small mapviews.
No one likes small mapviews.
If mapviews are tiny, then
users can't navigate around
in the view which
is frustrating.
And they're going to
be difficult to touch
with thumbs and even fingers.
So if you are going to use
a small map, for example,
in a hybrid view where you
show a list of results,
then make sure that
they're not navigable,
meaning that the
user can't actually
touch it and move it around.
So clearly, big maps
are the way to go.
Try and make the mapview
as large as you can.
It's the content that the
user should be immersed in.
And they should
not be distracted
by needless interactions.
This also makes the
map easier to interact
with thumbs and fingers.
Here's another best practice.
Don't position buttons
in the ow zone.
This will inconvenience
the user when
they have to interact with a
mapview with a single hand.
And also avoid cluttering the
screen with too many control
buttons and widgets, as you
can see in this example,
because it reduces
the amount of space
you have to display the map.
So to reduce clutter, put
your app's navigation controls
in the drawer.
Put frequently used
actions, for example,
to switch between list and
mapviews, and to do a search,
these should all go
into the action bar.
Put the map controls,
for example,
for filtering and overlay
control, on the map
surface itself.
And finally, try and avoid the
ow zone for button placement.
Use the thumb zone instead.
Here's another best practice.
Do not make touch
targets too small.
It's hard enough for
users to search and filter
to get to the results on
a map in the first place.
So don't make it
even harder for them
to select an actual
result on the map.
Think about clumsy
thumbs trying to press
a pin in a crowded map.
Another benefit of
taking this into account
is that it restricts
how many results
you can actually
display on the map.
So make sure that
the markers on a map
are large enough so that
they're easy to touch.
Try going higher than the
minimum 48 dip touch target,
and try and provide
enough padding
around each touch
target as well.
Also, make sure to have
multiple sizes of markers.
The larger the
marker size, the more
important that result should be.
That's all the time we
have for this episode.
In the next episode, part two,
I will share some best practices
around how to display
results on a map
and how to make this
information glanceable and easy
to consume for users on-the-go.
And if you haven't already,
please be sure to join our UX
community on Google+.
It's a place where we can
continue this discussion,
and you can meet
other people who
are just as passionate
about UX as you are.
Thanks for watching,
and goodbye.